[Music]
my progress has been accelerating in the
past few years as you have heard from
your short stock earlier and there are
many exciting and difficult challenges
that arise with increasing air
capabilities from figuring out how to
specify the complexity of human values
to machines to questions of policy and
governance and how to help our
policymakers manage the societal impacts
of a yet and the good news is that it's
not too early to work on these problems
now and in fact we have many awesome
people who are working in these problems
who are actually right here in this
audience
foi has funded 37 projects in ASAT and
many of those researchers have presented
their work at the workshop that preceded
this conference and over the next 20
minutes I'll talk about some overall
themes in this work and all the really
awesome progress that our researchers
have made we'll start with the question
of value learning how do we specify
complicated and sometimes contradictory
human values to machines the question of
what happens if you don't do a good job
of specifying what you want has been
extensively explored in fiction from
ancient fables like King Midas to
Sorcerer's Apprentice and we all know
what happened when King Midas asked
for everything he touched turned to gold
he got exactly what he asked for but not
what he wanted and I researchers have
some answers to how to provide this kind
of thing
with our AI systems some of our
researchers approach the question of
value learning through human feedback as
he earlier heard from Stuart Russell one
approach is to teach the agent by the
most trading human actions what a human
would do in a given situation and the
co-operative part of the inverse
reinforcement learning method for this
is that we don't just show the agent how
a human would make coffee perfectly but
we actually teach the agent how to make
coffee
Hawaiian Evans would point out that
human actions are often kind of
inconsistent and suboptimal and that
makes them more difficult to learn from
so he works on modifying inverse
reinforcement learning to account for
these human inconsistencies and biases
well cushy on Oh on the other hand would
say that human feedback is great but we
don't want to be giving our artificial
agents feedback every five seconds and
having them ask well is it okay to do
this it's okay to do that every five
seconds so we want we want them to make
use of human feedback much more
efficiently and that goes into the
question of how to make AI control
scaleable and this approach to this is
semi-supervised learning
another cluster of researchers addressed
the question of value learning through
building in moral concepts directly
francesca rossi works on specifying
ethical laws through various sorts of
constraints that depend on the context
that the agent is in on the other hand
medicine connoisseur looks for patterns
in human decision-making for example we
can give humans various sorts of
scenarios and ask them to rate like how
moral the action question was like
suppose a woman threw a stapler at
someone in the audience when they were
snoring while she was getting a talk is
that like our case that's how moral is
this and we could have a whole bunch of
scenarios like this and have sort of
human ratings for for these actions and
from this we can figure out some
relevant features that we can build into
AI systems and adrien Willer asks to
what extent we can make these moral
concepts that humans have more precise
and consistent even before we build them
into AI systems because there's a lot of
these inconsistencies that come up when
we start trying to specify things like
morality precisely for example what the
concept of fairness means to me might
mean something very different to every
single one of you and we need to make
that more precise another big challenge
in AI safety is robust self modification
for AI systems
how can our AI systems improved
themselves modified themselves while
retaining various safety properties that
we care about in other words how can we
prevent dr. Jekyll from turning into mr.
Hyde Romana Kumar approaches this
question using formal verification he
looks at the challenges of self
referential reasoning when agents try to
prove that they or as a future successor
agents will do the right thing and you
run into all sorts of logical paradoxes
like Galeras paradox like the sentence
is false when you want try to do this
kind of proof at the other hand past
owner brink takes a more empirical
approach if he thinks about how we can
get our AI systems to modify themselves
very gradually and test those
modifications excessively so we really
don't want to let dr. Jekyll
take a large swig of potion and turn
into mr. Hyde because it would be a
large modification not only make small
modifications to make the sub
modification of the agent more bounded
anomaly detection is another big
challenge in air safety how can we have
our AI systems recognized when they are
outside of the regime in which they were
trained and generalized appropriately
and conservatively from their past
experience in other words how can
artificial agents air systems act
reasonably in the presence of unknown
unknowns then borrowing an example here
from person yang where your training
data is something like a house but your
test data could be something like a
skyscraper the person's work helps the
air systems make good predictions and
without making any strong assumptions
about where the test data comes from Tom
Dietrich thinks about how to get a part
of the system monitor the rest of the
system and notice when when the system
is extrapolating and what it is outside
its training theater the other hand
machine League cautions us that we
should never do extrapolation because
extrapolation is fairly risky and we
should in fact look at our data and be
able to test whether it's just a normal
data point on adversarial data point
Brian Ziebart agrees with Machine about
the virtues of being pessimistic and
thinking about adversarial scenarios and
he asks what is the worst case that for
what the test data could be like that's
still like reasonably consistent with
the training data
last but certainly not least there are
the questions of how we can help our
policymakers manage the increasingly
tricky societal impacts of AI Heather
rough emphasizes the importance of
meaningful human control of autonomous
weapons and she thinks about how to
define this concept the tactical
operational and a strategic level Peter
sro thinks about autonomous weapons from
the perspective of liability and he asks
who is responsible for their actions and
what do we even mean by things like
autonomy and agency these are all
concepts that can be fairly difficult to
pin down
Marshall party focuses on the issue of
job automation that you heard about from
Eric's talk earlier and he is organizing
an event in Washington DC that will
bring together various key stakeholders
to help the government respond to this
challenge nick bostrom takes a more
general view of policy and he thinks
about what are the relevant desiderata
as we transition into an era of machine
intelligence such as how do we enable
global coordination and how do we make
sure that a I really benefits everyone
these research themes that I just talked
about are only part of the work of our
grantees unfortunately I didn't have
time to talk about the amazing work of
the rest the rest of our researchers and
this is all part of this vast landscape
of ASAT research so actually Richard
from FLI has put together this really
cool map
ASAT topics and how they relate to each
other which you can I encourage you to
play around with that the future of
weather org slash landscape and I think
this really shows how much more there
still remains to be done even given all
the progress we've made so far there is
a growing community of researchers who
are working on all these problems and
this community spans both academia and
Industry and independent researchers and
many of those teams that are here on the
slide didn't truly exist two years ago
so this community has really been
expanding dramatically since Verto Rico
and that has been really inspiring I
would like all the FOI researchers who
are here in the audience to please stand
up and wait but make yourself known I'd
like to thank all of you for the really
amazing work that you've been doing the
past couple of years
you
[Music]